you got this you're killing you're
crushing it everyone loves you be you
don't even worry about it he says
anything
so i say
brick house
i just take it out of my
this is what i say i don't even know why
i haven't thought of this song breakouts
i am not i like that that was in your
wedding i don't even know where it came
from
the rest of the night
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
buzz bug
oh what you got there buddy
oh damn thank you i did the same i did
the same thing i just got a regular gold
one yeah but i'd [ __ ] all that because
i'll lose it so i just i don't know
are you used to it yet i'm not yet um
yeah good day but how tight is that
though nah it's good yeah me that's what
it is but if i put soap it'll come off
yeah yeah me too you know what i mean
but that's why sometimes i like i take
it off when i'm washing my hands or
whatever it's like that just to get used
but i haven't really i don't feel it
doesn't feel yeah you know i've never
worn the ring i hate i don't i don't
like rings but i told my god
i wanted to get like a one of those dope
man rings that's like something it's
thicker and like yeah but then i was
like what what rogan has that yeah think
what
does he wear a rubber one the rubber
oh no no i'm talking about they're like
some of them like it's like they look
like three layers oh no there might be
diamonds in the middle or something like
that that would be very like a chris
angel ring that'd be sick yeah i like
that or where you're like your class
ring yeah like a super bowl right yeah i
wanted to get a tattoo but she was like
i actually don't remember i don't know i
don't get the argument it's forever i
don't remember where we fell on that
just do it i don't know it's cool it
looks cool with the watch though yeah it
doesn't match the watch it is i mean
it's just kind of like yeah you kind of
feel tethered i hate brands
yeah you're not a but you're a girl yeah
i like necklaces i like bracelets i just
hate [ __ ] on my fingers it just it seems
annoying i don't know
i don't know it's like an old school i
don't know philly is old school well
married man
yeah yeah things are you guys are acting
different you're the same
acting differently you're just dead oh
no i got it
i really do i feel like you know yeah um
you guys have the same wedding band too
i know that's did you get a discount or
how to make a a week well as the
department as the you know
the veteran of marriage yes yeah yeah i
call them every week and i say what what
do i expect this week well it's week two
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but this one is a doozy
yeah week two get ready
was that the picture i took
oh that's a good picture it's a good
pick yeah you had i really enjoyed your
wedding me too yeah thanks because it
wasn't long drawn out yeah yeah yeah too
serious yeah the valves were easy also
we got to work on the mic situation
right the audio okay because your vows
become hurt i was furious i was
i can't describe the rage i had when
they were messing up your
vows and then the lady who was like the
leader of it
her mic worked on like yeah
give your mic to him yeah right that was
the that was the whole crowd was saying
that it was almost turned into a thing
give up your mom yeah
it's okay though and uh we we got it on
video so right right yeah yeah it just
wasn't it just wasn't uh yeah a ton of
times um
well we might
watch it not a ton no you watch it once
yeah yeah it's nice to have though
it starts out though but then also the
the your your brother's speech was
fantastic
she was that funny when i brought him on
the road yeah i know he's the best of
his life that's good look at bobby bobby
also dressed up for mine and didn't
dress up for yours how do you feel about
that well he probably got heat oh he's
like he told me well that's what he said
the first time when he walked in he was
like i said oh you dressed up for her
and he was like
he was like i got so much heat i can't i
didn't
rick glassman did your uh yeah oh that's
great he was great yeah rick's the best
yeah yeah i've been to santa barbara in
a hot second either it's nice it's
changed man there's a bunch
dude that area is really great um that
area is a great picture did you see that
picture than your dad probably which one
right there that's his dad oh that's
sweet yeah yeah oh yeah your dad's so
nice man it's a trip to see my dad with
all like my buddies it's just such a
trip to see like
because also he
has been there like when i started doing
stand-up and he like knew all you guys
in the beginning and [ __ ] it's just like
wild like he took a picture with max
amini and i was like god damn it he's
known him forever yeah your dad uh
grabbed me when uh i think you were
doing the first dancing grab me he's
like i can't believe
we didn't meet before oh i know yeah
i know i know it's crazy we have not
said it's crazy
all right i know it's crazy yeah it was
good man and father's day dude too one
two oh right all right then yeah
for you
sort of day you know you're working
which is disrespectful yeah yeah that's
disrespectful to your culture
um i didn't know it was a holiday today
that's how white i am
well because it was yesterday right yeah
well i knew it was a holiday because my
kid had school his summer oh okay and i
was like why because it drives me nuts
when they have random days off like oh
yeah awareness yeah yeah yeah you're
making [ __ ] up yeah yeah and then he's
like oh dad i don't have camp tomorrow
i'm like why don't you have camp you
think it's some june i'm like oh
june 10 wow well you know it's about
time y'all yeah
well i said back to you i said what
y'all have done baby ian made me laugh
ian edwards made me laugh yesterday dude
he was
uh
he's he's black if for those of you that
don't know but he was like great comic
but he oh dude monster yeah great so
good but he [ __ ] was like someone was
somebody said it was we were gonna we
were gonna surprise you for juneteenth
because he was like the only black guy
around and he said he said yeah they did
too
dude that [ __ ] killed me
he's so funny dude he's so funny
dude but you know what made me laugh was
your [ __ ] comment back to david
arnold on your instagram when you said
sorry you got married before the
internet
dude that made me laugh do it he put me
he put he posted me on his instagram and
he was like wedding continues everyone's
getting married and then david arnold
was like talk to me when you guys get to
19 years and he said sorry you got
married before the internet liar i
laughed out loud that's funny because he
was just talking what it was he didn't
even look at the picture i just thought
he thought he was doing posting about
your posting
you know what i mean and i just was like
come on man so funny dude well you uh
there it is
yeah man
um can't you be proud bro you know
but also uh
how
you know what by the way just with
comments people think that's some sort
of like free press you know what do you
mean what i mean like they think it's
the free like they're a part of the free
press oh so they get to go into your
comments and talk about stuff that has
nothing to do with you know so i tell
you what man i i have just oh yeah i've
i all i've been doing is deleting oh
yeah yeah comments yeah you know what i
mean i'm like this is my this is our
happy day i know it's insane like i
don't need your help for wedding picks
just just yeah just what people were
putting out there just like guys
whatever put that on your page but even
the russian bots those [ __ ] i'll post
my son and the russians i'm an idiot
like dude who wants to get sucked off
today yeah i'm like no it's a picture of
my kids hey russian bots have a little
respect i do respect
i know i respect how they don't
discriminate posts
i i do respect that you post one like
your dad died or some [ __ ] you guys been
getting like
text messages from like random like i've
done they go like this they'll go like
hey bobby or hey dan you're right
and they got me because once it was like
hey it's blah blah blah and i was and i
have a friend with that name i'm like oh
you changed your number are you still in
blah blah and then he was like uh no
come on it's ryan from san francisco and
like oh oh this is a fake thing and then
once you just give them a little kernel
bro
30 random tags really hey it's
larry oh that's funny you know you're
like oh [ __ ] oh wow no yeah i never once
you give him a colonel it's off to the
right it's always like a fake asian girl
and she says
you know this is soon so whatever and
then i go is this so-and-so and i go no
it's not first time i every day i was
like no i don't what no i don't think i
get the wrong once you respond it's on
and then she go then they'll go oh well
you know i like meeting new people and
i'm like oh
that's hilarious you know what i mean it
just turns into this thing yeah because
they're hoping to get money because
you're like me new people and those
lonely dudes out there like
me too
and then it's i don't think you're
talking about somebody send me your
website that i can do that i'm not gonna
look at it right
here let me catch up you now to stop
dude
do you
uh
yeah how much you're gonna cost for you
to next time tell your friends that do
this too just stop here's 30 bucks dude
um
i know guys that have been got bro like
they sent dick pics and they're like
then they're like seventy five thousand
dollars that's and harry you know guys
too by the way oh i actually i know no
one you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah i don't want dude that got got
like that yeah yeah but then he was like
amy from ireland guys like cool no
it's a facebook facebook yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they they start talking and
they make it all sexy and they might
send some titty pics or something and
then like send this back and then they
screenshot everything and they're like
we're going to send this to your to your
job we're going to send this to your
boom boom that's awesome my buddy was
like oh i'm a comedian first of all i
[Laughter]
mike's taking it the lights all perfect
yeah
we uh got it gets up and moves the
camera
nick walks by
i thought it was dope at your wedding it
was a picture thing where people take
the pictures oh yeah yeah that was good
i came solo like a loser yeah but i had
no way to take a picture with so
exciting i'll do it with you man so
we're going to take one but we're going
to pretend that we are holding brian and
theo
yeah what with the lady taking place
like let's cut that out you two get
together right now
it was fun
that picture you and me with the picture
me and chris my mom goes eric's sexy all
right man you know what
your mom trying to smash i think so man
sorry two weeks too late i know you're
two weeks yeah my mom that's why i told
her and that's the first time i met your
fiance yeah your kids are me i'm sorry
your wife you're kidding me big like so
her dad's 16 dude her dad yeah at the
wedding he hugged
her dad dick in your face dude he was
like yeah man her dad's it was really
because he's always one of the tallest
dudes did did hit did her dad come and
talk to you
because he watches podcasts because
really so he was like walking around
like he was like oh take your shoes off
that's funny and he was like oh yeah
he knows all the stuff did he do
anything with it yeah he played
basketball for a little while oh thank
god i want level though
he he was like semi-pro he was trying to
be yeah all right all right that's good
that's good that's good bro i had one of
your friends i'm not throwing any [ __ ]
when your friends come over i'm
literally i'm i was so hungry the food
came food was delicious so i'm scarf i
was so hungry i'm scarfing it down
trying to stay on my diet scarfing down
and there's who whoever was around me i
think was craig and then marshall they
got up to get drinks so there's two
empty seats yeah and everybody sat down
he knew from back in day i guess he's a
high school wrestling coach yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh dude and i look one of
my best friends
all right that's great but rising coach
sits down he goes i've been dying to ask
you man
i coach high school wrestling yeah some
kids that want to get involved in mma
yeah yeah i mean where do you even start
oh yeah i went like this
what yeah it was where did he even start
i was like you know there's a lot of
hard work just starving back to when
yeah yeah he's like yeah but then dude
i'm talking a 30 minute
deep dive oh really on mma but that's
how people i mean people do that about
like i i hate that just say you hate it
i totally get it it's like somebody
asking me like you know hey so how do
you start in comedy hey hey [ __ ] off
if it wasn't chris's friend i probably
wouldn't you know what i mean he was a
nice guy hey go [ __ ] yourself man like
you can't skip steps yeah well the worst
is when they go i mean comedy how do you
even start in comedy i'm like oh we're
gonna start with the origin story yeah i
don't know dude i'm trying to you know
what you do in those situations just go
hey man that's a deep conversation yeah
and it's not for right now thanks you
know what i mean and they that some
people get it
i don't have that courage i went like
this is that cotton candy and then be
like
oh you think that's better
i don't know i apologize if he's
watching this now
is that cotton candy i was like we'll
talk later and [ __ ] beeline for it we
got uh a couple uh wedding books okay
cool very small oh nice all right let's
go no i want big ones uh well yours is
what it hasn't arrived okay i've got
another light for you so you're not
another one by the way another light oh
yeah you're asking for the light yeah
it'll be here next week wear it up for
there yeah oh great oh nice no but i was
gonna say before we even go there by the
way uh because chris had a destination
an expensive destination wedding yeah
yeah okay it was you know well it was a
drive but he counted as a destination i
didn't mind the drive because it's at
800 a night hotel i had to stay i know i
know
so you're not getting a gift
i told her i was like man what about
she's like there's another one there was
another hotel they were all expensive
brothers
how about yeah i missed eric's wedding i
was on the road i was like sorry man and
i was like what can i do
say let me get your gift what do you
want he goes i want ps5
but i i didn't i don't know
so i was like yeah no doubt all right
i'll i'll get it i'll bring it to the
studio so i don't know video games i
don't play you know i got
kids i don't play [ __ ] video games
and so i hit up my brother i'm like yo
where can i because he knows all that
[ __ ] i'm like where can you get ps5 he's
like are you [ __ ] yeah do you know
how hard these things are i know
but i thought he might have had a
connection
you know he'd get a ferrari you've got a
ferrari connection you got it there's
one in your ferrari you don't even know
about it yeah dude dig deep you'll get a
connection yeah you've got to come back
i didn't know it was mission impossible
i know i thought well i actually didn't
either i got i have one
a ps5 right of course you do i have it
yeah if any of our listeners have one uh
i'll buy from you
2k that's okay
i'm helping you out no you're helping
you out you shouldn't even done it like
that you should no you could have been
like that's 500 and he was like it's 2
000 brendon
oh yeah that's the movie let's see bro
ah
that's how he got where he is dude he's
crafty he's a businessman he's savvy
last thing about your wedding i did tear
up when calvin was in the little tuxedo
that got me yeah and then your your
adorable audio on your vows so sobered
me right up no my vows were good well i
couldn't i couldn't hear you they were i
heard probably have hearing problems
every people heard it nothing no i
couldn't hit yeah
barely your ears are you know what i
mean
i i heard him it was great yeah thank
you it was great i heard about a few
things about elevator that's it yeah
yeah
oh my god
that's all you heard it no all i know
but i'm just saying like it's like to
simplify it like that no it was chris
told a very beautiful story he it was it
was a great story form vows about an
elevator and how his life is like an
elevator and
and and like the different stops is all
it was it was beautiful it was like well
thought out and it was all the way out
of your emotions better than i did
because i was a blubbering mess i was
shocked
i was shocked but the way it was because
the story was so it was it was like you
had to tell this story in a certain way
so it was great you didn't go for cheese
right where were you sitting there where
are we sitting oh i was sitting like on
the right side like how many rows up i
was closer yes
they said like the back few rows it was
tough
yeah yeah i heard it in spots that's why
i was like all right he missed his
elevator i killed it
but i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna send you the audio i'll send
you the audio
send it you know it would be great it's
like when we do get it the video we have
to get the video and then play
him saying that
i was furious
yeah but anyways by the way i know we're
going on and on but again it was
beautiful i had two weeks and for me
i've had two weeks of love it was great
you know i i was in i i didn't even tear
up when i wanted to during your vows but
it was like towards the i think we
teared up at the same time ugh you know
because it was like because i had the
visual in my head of like
what you were like and then the elevator
opened and then it was hurt yeah yeah
and i was like this [ __ ] i know
it was beautiful i teared up when calvin
walked down when your dad started giving
a speech yeah yeah and her mom gave her
uh yeah she was great she was a
newscaster she was a newscaster i was
going to say her mom
it was long yeah it was long it was long
yeah when the bride had four endings it
was like lord of the rings
and i was like oh small flags yeah yeah
and she's like and then she moved to
venice so like small flags and i was
like i dig this psychology degree yeah
no not not cheerleader gymnastics
and then the the bridesmaids got up and
they were talking about a vortex and i
looked at enrique and this one i uh had
uh uh ed uh ian cracking up i go uh
because enrique runs the laugh actor
give him the light give him a like
oh oh that was beautiful dude you want
the beautiful he go ahead i'm just going
i'm trying to interrupt you but i just
want to say one thing one thing i that
it's like when you know someone when
you're like friends with someone you
know they're things and then someone
tells a story about them when you know
them well you're there yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
she told the story of like you guys
watching the hallmark yeah yeah yeah
yeah and like i was like i i was so had
joy for myself i was because i was like
of course chris doesn't like hallmark
yeah yeah so i felt myself like i was
there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
i thought that was yeah that was great
you could tell she's comfortable in
front of yeah
it's like she she was a beast she
handled it actually the mom handled the
whole thing
just even now she just she addressed
everything and just was like i really
felt a lot of love i felt that her
family really appreciates you and
accepts you and it was like it was
beautiful guys i'm telling you right now
you missed a girl we had to follow
[ __ ] yours dude yours was amazing so
yeah oh what's this this is eric's gift
oh
nice
why am i a mayor though that's a good
one come on bro oh dude you know why
you're out there you don't come on
in the in the gay community you're a
bear bro
hashtag gay pride look at this i felt
like you're very blue from jungle
book-esque
that's awesome i love the glasses that's
hilarious yeah that's fantastic yeah
love it thank you and then and then the
i keep getting a lot of comments about
like they keep saying like why don't
they just add this thing already
takes a lot of work and then also the
glasses there's an e in there which is
very cool it's like your area yeah
yeah or it's an asian baby i noticed the
small things
might be an asian baby that
that's awesome
we just got to add that to the intro now
yeah
all right um and theo's dealing with
personal family issues so he's out for a
little bit yeah but he'll be back
yeah he had a
hit a son no
um yeah no he's dealing with his native
american son was finally born yeah
right right right right
and here he is is this the weekend
what's up the king the sting the wing
and the sing
i got a little debate club
i got a couple weddings coming up and
i have a few
females that are saying oh let me be
your plus one let me be your blessed one
and i'm thinking
i might just go with no plus one because
i don't want these you know to look at
these wedding photos later on and be
like oh who's ed with some random chick
yeah i'd rather just
fly solo so what do you think flying
solo to the wedding
or just bringing some random chick solo
daddy first bridesmaids you're a single
bridesmaids you're having fun
but also
i feel this dude there he's got a bunch
of weddings coming up dude everybody's
getting married now because they're cool
for [ __ ] covid yeah it's insane i
mean that's why ours are back-to-back
and then the [ __ ] do we have so many
yeah do you yeah we have more this
summer like yeah it's crazy
i will say about this
at my wedding four of my
four friends of mine came up to me and
were like dude you got me thinking about
my ex
like like four of them did that they
just brought in man it was like gloves
in the air at a wedding oh yeah yeah so
i like
my advice to this guy is go solo yeah no
dude go i'm telling go solo yeah you
might fall in love like eric's talking
about he's older or you're just slaying
dick from wedding away i know but the
bridesmaids there's nothing makes them
more yeah i know but also dude don't you
feel like though when you're at a
wedding it's definitely fun if you're
single and there are other single people
but like
there's this kind of like i don't want
to say sadness but if you're there alone
and like there's love in there what age
you are
i guess yeah you're right
i had a first of all it also yeah
yeah but it's also depends on the
wedding too like you know we didn't you
know i didn't have the richie rich
wedding you know what i'm saying so it
was like you know where was yours at i'm
saying we we we did it we made sure to
invite people to rachel was clear if
it's not a significant other i don't
want them they have to come along yeah
yeah so it's like not everybody gets a
plus one at a wedding i think that
that's good though i think that like
what she said rachel i think that that's
how it should be yeah if you don't come
with i don't think well we didn't do
that but if if you have a significant
other then they come if you don't
then they don't bring them randomly
because you know what you're saying
about the pictures about the p what he's
saying about the pictures too my my girl
was saying she said the same thing she
was just like i don't want my pictures
of like so we're like well who's that
girl or who's that guy i think that
that's good
so it's like i feel like it's i think it
is something about you know what love is
in the air and you can meet people like
ian edwards at my wedding
he was doing good he he told me later
like yeah man went out on a i'm putting
you know
have you ever seen wedding um excuse me
yeah somebody's at home like what
but he went out my wedding my wedding is
weird too because like rachel has a lot
of model friends so it looked like
[Music]
wnbc all yeah her friends were like
there's five of them and they're all in
different colored dresses hilarious five
eleven six foot they're all like that
and then it was all
and all these weird comics yeah yeah
yeah all these short weird [ __ ]
trolls
yeah solo's the way to go also to that
point like the hoes don't deserve to be
at your friend's wedding like if it's a
close friend you can't bring somebody
well you're here to eat your food but
but also seeing all the personal close
family and friends
you don't deserve that i don't know man
yeah maybe go solo but i'm done with the
slang and dick [ __ ] idea because well
you don't want to be
i mean look if it happens and you get
laid that's awesome and that's fun but
like
dude you don't want to go with like
different chicks and [ __ ] and like it
doesn't mean anything also you look like
kind of a dick you're like yeah pay for
this one now i know yeah yeah this one
wants the salmon yeah
yeah
wait what who are you bringing i know i
know yeah
it's tasty yeah oh dude yeah the food
the the taste test was the [ __ ] dude
they brought it all out the stuff that
didn't make the cut even that was good
and you you guys even oh you know i
didn't eat the [ __ ] i left before the
cake was cut oh you're stupid because
after that there were churros out there
no i saw the chicken chicken sandwiches
oh you don't know daddy has cavities
yeah i can't eat that [ __ ] yeah that
don't bother me tater tot there were
tater tots i didn't even get those oh
dude i drink
two cold brew coffees
that was good huh the coffee was good
yeah i might have a
i might have a
you know a baby because of
his wedding oh yeah that would be
awesome oh that'd be sick him chris you
put it in oh god why is it so extra
gross when he does it
we left that wedding and i walked across
the street like come on girl you know
what time it is you know what
it's mister nasty yeah we got to like we
have to combine all the names it'll be
like you know chris christine
alvin
we're gonna have one of those but your
kid or your kiss was
pretty sexy though the first sex
it was like was it a lot yeah
rachel made us practice dude
you guys just decided whether to do like
she told me we had to practice like [ __ ]
you know yeah that's cute she'd be like
okay we're gonna do it like this we're
gonna have one kiss and then we're gonna
do another kiss you know but she like
came at me it was like it was see but
here's the problem about going to
weddings because my girl went to
schultz's with me she didn't go to yours
because we couldn't find the babysitter
so i went solo like a loser but yeah
eric was kind of my date right but the
problem is
is when because me and her just got
married at the the
courthouse
let's invest in the house what are we
doing yes but then actually i know where
this is going yeah and then you know
she's like oh this is so nice like i was
watching this little girl i was like oh
[ __ ]
and then she was like how is chris
that's all right yeah good kind of
she'll see the video and should because
he was kind of [ __ ] liar
dude have a party surprise her with it
yeah you could i don't think she
wouldn't want to be surprised she's like
surprised her with the idea are you uh
well you can have like a you know what
you have a quinceanera at the same time
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah was there
uh well i could just set 60 grand on
fire you know yeah i know i know it's
just
it's one of those do that anyway with
your dumb
shoes the vitriol yeah yeah how dare you
that's fair this guy man
she doesn't see this podcast um make
sure you don't know how much these shoes
are that i know
he got gold what he got gold shoelaces
in one you don't want to spin on the
wedding
happy you're right you are a piece of
[ __ ] you're right fair point how did
both of our [ __ ] mics break this
[ __ ] well it's just this thing pops
off what's up with uh new lights coming
yeah yeah yeah what's up with uh wait so
was schultz's wedding extravagant
no he was at uh
his girl's parents house if they have a
house in santa barbara there's food
trucks for the food good good drinks
like you're super short fun
like if you have comics as friends
they're the best ones to give the
speeches oh yeah yeah they're fire yeah
they can read the room of course they're
not their bombing they get out speaking
of so chris had a great pre-party right
and then that was when he they made it
very clear this is when you're supposed
to give speeches yeah yeah yeah yeah
because you're not going to be able to
speak right
right and then his his one friend goes
up dan yeah yeah
and just
nobody wanted to go up after him
no it was honestly
as a comedian so i went up and i gave a
um whatever
when was this it was the night before
you were invited bro yeah and so
so and so i was doing sets
so
it was a wine
what even it was like a winery like and
i was they were like you should say
something i was like i'll say something
and i was like oh this is like you go
back to like open mics like oh i've done
[ __ ] rooms like this you know what i
mean and i'm like this is just a
terrible room
for
anything comedy so i'll just do a
regular speech if i get laughs okay
i did it i got a few chuckles i made fun
of my dad whatever and then uh i got off
and i was like if anyone wants to do a
speech
dan comes up doesn't know that this room
is just a
it's a [ __ ] death trap like for for
comedy and he went up with a few jokes
and it was a death trap so he was just
like and that was it for everybody else
everyone's like
oh i thought he crushed it because he
bombed so everyone's like oh i'm good
you can't so everyone's like i'm good
but you can't crush it yeah i mean
unless you're not set up for success
yeah even at my wedding like i i was
surprised at the people that went up and
i was surprised at the people that
didn't go up you know but at the same
time i look and i go i get it you know
what i mean like it's like did you did
you ever have a thought process that you
wanted to go up the whole time at your
wedding i was like i want to say i don't
know but that would have been fine i
know i know but at the same time i get
why you yeah yeah yeah because i thought
the same thing too because you know for
me i was thinking to myself do i want to
go up and talk and the thing is like
without you exactly that was what i came
to i was like exactly that's why i was
out on yours like when i saw the notes
i'm like i have some fire [ __ ] in my
pocket right now yeah i'm like but this
isn't yeah but you imagine i just get up
there
hey chris but even at the winery even at
the wine thing it's like i thought to
myself i'm going to go up here and i'm
going to crush yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i'm like this ain't about me yeah i
and my instinct would be to like be
super funny
i was like you know what this ain't my
time that's what i said i'm saying that
i'm like oh this this isn't about you
dumbass because like her face had some
heart felt like my stuff was even me
[ __ ] i started crying dude i had to give
a speech at my brother's wedding i mean
nobody heard anything i was like
anchorman in the [ __ ] phone booth
like no one heard anything i was i just
couldn't get anything out i was just
crying but kristen's family was already
like chris is the funniest guy we've
ever met and i didn't want to crush that
you know what yeah yeah yeah yeah i was
like
realizing oh there's other really funny
people in the world i almost stood up i
must stood up and said [ __ ] take that
comedian table yeah
oh you had so you you i yeah it was even
during her vows you chimed in at the
perfect time but anyway i what i'm
saying though is i i get as a comedian
in a crowd and having a wedding and
having comedians in the crowd i i get
why like a lot of them didn't it is
interesting yeah you know what i mean
yeah my table was so fun though the
comments oh yeah yeah oh yeah it's fun
i guess he started coming with he was
the pink suit he looked like a cocaine
drug dealer from oh andy and he started
dancing when he started dancing i was
like well this guy's fantastic that guy
andy kozell is first of all always
dresses like hunter s thompson that guy
is
one of the most fun guys to be around
like just he at a diner you're
i mean he's so funny dude and if he
could just talk to that i know i know i
i always tell him and he still does
stand up right now he does stand up i'm
saying because i'm not there's no [ __ ] i
just don't see him around no no he
doesn't he doesn't he doesn't hustle you
know but he is [ __ ] funny him dancing
i was laughing my ass oh dude he's
[ __ ] great how about the band
oh my god where'd you find them yeah
they were such a good band oh dude
multi-ethnic too
band bro
dude first of all i hired him because i
saw the lead singer because the guy or
the no no no no no the white dude the
older the leader he was the leader one
that was playing
exactly
i just saw a picture of him and i was
like that guy is a wedding singer
we hire that guy okay he's a great band
that guy comes up to me before the
[ __ ] wedding i gotta tell this on my
podcast too but that guy comes up to me
before the wedding and he is like hey
man i'm rick i just want a rich whatever
it was i want to let you know i'm so
happy to be here
um uh we're we're so happy is there what
kind of style do you want us to do and i
was like oh bro i saw your video do your
thing you guys are amazing do whatever
you want he was like is there anything i
could sing like we'd do kind of a
classic rock kind of thing and i was
like it's perfect do that do whatever
you got just play the hits you got it he
was like all right let me know and i
said i will but you got don't worry
about it he does he starts doing it
they're crushing you saw right i was
like i mean they're amazing every song
is like this song that you hear on the
[ __ ] show remember
yeah
unbelievable they're doing shout i hate
that wedding song and i'm like okay i
hate that like they're but they're good
though right
they take a break they come back they
come out the guy says hey man just wanna
say if there's anything
he's looking for i'm missing anything
yeah yeah i'm like you should've been
like drake mitch no this guy's looking
for recommendations but i'm so happy
with what he's doing yeah so i say to
him i'm like listen dude there he is
right there i was like listen buddy
you're killing it just keep doing what
you're doing i love it and he said all
right well just let me know at any time
i say i will goes does another set
then comes back i'm sitting down he
comes up to me again and he says hey man
if there's anything you want me to say
this is the third time right this is the
third time he's because he's all out of
songs no well no that's not what it is
it's because he's been to other weddings
and he's probably been like later they
said hey how come you didn't do whatever
it is yeah right so i say listen man
you got this you're killing you're
crushing it everyone loves you be you
don't even worry about it he says
anything
so i say
brick house
i just take it out of my this is what i
say i don't even know why i haven't
thought of this song breakouts
i am not i like that that was in your
wedding i don't even know where it came
from
i haven't
[Applause]
and he go this is what he does dude
this is exactly what he does i don't but
this is what he does he goes like this
he goes like this and he goes
oh
man
i love you man i love you
i see he says dude
yes
thank you so much for letting me be here
and i said
of course man and he walks away and as
he's walking away he says it feels so
good
okay
it's crazy
and then he's crazy the rest of the
night
to the point where you almost want to go
hey bro
after seven attempts still haven't
earned it i still haven't heard a brick
house like what happened to breakout
dude it was the it was [ __ ] hilarious
on the comment card you put everything
was great
it just was looking for brickhouse
that made me at the [ __ ] conversation
three times it was a waste
that's great oh you know what's great
about a wedding too well because you
know someone you know someone like this
like i've known chris for years now but
i've never seen chris dance oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't do i go i go uh
out there just like yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
all your coolness
[ __ ] and you're all
yeah it's my wedding i was like yeah
that makes sense yeah you got a dad you
got a dance yeah i saw a lot of weirdos
out there like you know rick glassman
can dance bobby lee can dance your boy
uh the cocaine dealer from miami can
dance
yeah like some people were dancing yeah
i know it was fun all right what we got
all right what else yeah
theo
eric
chris
and of course
oh the gringo poppy
himself
first off congratulations chris and eric
you all made a horrible mistake based on
my dad's previous three marriages
today i have a king of their sting it
for you
bringing your hydro flask to the open
bar to get filled up before the flight
home
i don't i don't like paying seven
dollars a little shot on the airplane
but i can bring 32 ounces of single malt
scotch for free
so can get or sting it
whatever i just said [ __ ] about this
that's great
whatever just said
dude wow this guy's energy i love it um
so
he's saying flask on a plane yeah yeah
basically
being a drunk mess on a plane that's
what he's saying
yeah being a piece of [ __ ]
yeah it's being that guy on the plane
that's all like you know
hey it's always weird like there's this
dad who i'm super close with that my son
jitsu i go today
and he he's like loud like
he's the only dad i talked to he's so
loud this last time i'm like what the
[ __ ] can we go get uh my son always eats
his pizza if he does good i go hey we're
gonna get pizza he won't bring your son
he's like yeah i'll go he's so loud i'm
like bro you're loud as [ __ ]
he has a water bottle like this
pure vodka bro i'm like
what the fact that people think like
it's a flex or like you're gonna be like
yeah man well i just went why would you
share it
what's wrong with do you think i was
sitting there
like what are we doing here you gonna
have this fun time and that's why you're
loud as [ __ ] i always have a thing with
these kind of people though like they
don't like maybe well yeah you [ __ ]
if i sees your podcast and he's like
well yeah of course he wants some but
like he should have told me but like
dude there are people that like don't
like they they put themselves
on to you and they're not receiving you
the way
you know you're portraying yourself like
i was at the coffee bean and tele if you
know how i do it there i [ __ ] used to
run this block over the cold water right
anymore though no they don't even have
it anymore no to the point where it was
in your wife's vows yeah it was
that well that got me good hard i left
hard we all did she didn't know what she
did i was pissed that that got the
biggest laugh i was like
but um she headlined she gave me she did
so um but uh and and and i i used to see
this guy all the time we used to talk
[ __ ] you know me you know me right
this guy knew me we used to talk all the
time you should go company
and then one day he says dude i got a
great book for you to read and it's like
this book on buddhism and i'm like bro
you know i'm not going to read that
because you know me right this whole
[ __ ] it was like the wedding singer it's
like why did we have that conversation
three [ __ ] times yeah people do that
but it's like yeah so people are pushing
themselves and you're like you're not
receiving me bro no but i can't see what
the thing is like when you're in a
moment like what he's talking about
you're with somebody and like they're
acting weird right yeah yeah yeah and
then and then like you get a whiff of
their breath
that always just turns me off so much if
it's alcohol injury yeah because then
i'm like oh so one you're either like
you're drunk and not present yeah well
yeah you know you're like you're not
present then you're not aware of like
and so then it's like you're having your
own experience and you're bringing me
into it and i don't want to be there
that's where i was at yeah yeah i
my buddy the other day we came to the
store uh ours of the improv and i could
tell like he was just acting weird
acting weird hey are you on drugs
shrooms
what
yeah bro it's it's a wednesday at eight
o'clock yeah yeah yeah this is from the
guy what time is it
it's 12 on a monday
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i won't say who it is but one of the
comics was like hey man you want some
opens up this it looks like mints at my
wedding opens up it's all shrooms i go
no no what no tomorrow's father's day
and uh you know we're those come you
don't mess with that stuff i go
not when i get a drive home and be up at
six for father's day to be present
king in this thing in the wing um
congratulations chris and eric on your
weddings um
you make a beautiful couple
debate club would you ever wear a kilty
or wedding
thank you william wallace
that action is awesome oh i love it i
really i wanted to go to battle i'll run
through the wall for this [ __ ] dude i
would have an off-white kill i'd stunt
on all you guys with a hole in that dick
part yeah just no the [ __ ] just the
absolute holy [ __ ] you have to lift it
up sick
i love kicks and i'd be singing
you know guilt make sense though i i
yeah i i think that they're nice because
uh
i thought like you sweating [ __ ] in
pants you probably sweat less in a skirt
yeah just open but it's tough because it
is a at the end of the day in america we
call it a skirt right so unless you're
harry styles you can't really rock that
[ __ ] and not get beat up on the streets
or you go to catholic school right i
would i would uh kilt make sense though
yeah i guess they do i don't know i
wonder if like if like you just came to
this world and you saw it as a man you
probably wouldn't think of anything
feminine you know you'd probably just be
like oh you could you decided yeah yeah
yeah well yeah like that's all i said
if all i fed my son is william wallace
you know like yeah you'd want to
yeah yeah yeah and then he goes to
school like hey you're in a dress right
right yeah that's true i remember
something that influenced me when i was
a kid the first time the first time i
you know that
like my mom wanted to go see raiders of
the lost ark oh yeah you know and i was
like i want to see this crap you know i
was just i remember this clearly being
like this is going to be stupid
really i don't know i didn't know yeah
you know what i mean i was like a little
kid yeah man when i got home i wanted a
whip yeah i wanted a hat yeah wow you
know and i was running around the house
yeah you know and so it's just that it's
that kind of thing yeah influence you're
like i'm my hero growing up one of them
was arnold schwarzenegger and i thought
i'd look swoll if i got a flat top like
him so we went to the great clips and i
was like i want a flat top
really i'm like can you do it he's all
say less can't really do it and my hair
was
awful but i thought i looked like arnold
schwarzenegger he's on a flat top yeah i
used to have the i wanted the when i was
a kid i wanted the 90210 luke perry
jason priestley yeah dude
i'll send a pick in
it bro
[ __ ] off bro
well i'm with you on that i've been sick
i felt so good
with it man you don't even know don't
even get me started
yes
boy i had a duck tale back here like
that's you know what i mean bro i gotta
see that no we should get pictures
because i have a picture was like that
part is like you know i come from a
generation i know no pics i have to
finally have to draw you yeah
that's a draw like a wanted poster
like i'm at the venice beach
oh man all right
hold on r.i.p to luke perry man i loved
that dude
he was a nice guy yeah he was great on
uh he was also in um
uh he was he looks like brian oh yeah
yeah i know you look like brian if brian
was on hgh for 30 years [ __ ] no uh he
was on once once upon a time in
hollywood that was his last movie oh he
doesn't he was great
he was on uh he does look like brian he
was doing well he was on riverdale we
were on a plane together and then he
died like diamond piece what do you die
from being too handsome i forget i don't
know
he's good he's a good guy we get a dime
pieces what she was just talking about
it would end with a wolf she sent in uh
videos a couple times before she's a
stripper in cleveland oh that's right
she came out to the thick boy song on
the pole
what do you mean what's up guys congrats
on the naturals uh jessie here and i'm
here to bring you another king or sting
it
so uh to give a little backstory my
husband i recently had a vow renewal
ceremony in australia where he's from
and one of our friends gifted us a
commissioned drawing of one of our
family photos of us with our dogs here
uh nick i'm going to need you to pull up
the side by side
everyone looks like i have down syndrome
you can see
this did not turn out great and
i just have to have you all hang it or
sting it what do you think of
commissioned drawings for a wedding gift
oh gang
buzz buzz soar and sorry eric i'm not
going to sing for you
wait this little dime that's not
terrible drama no that's terrible no he
looks like him but she looks but brennan
like she's on the spectrum like she
doesn't look good and she's gorgeous
yeah but also it it's still bad yeah but
also you have two wolves look at that
nice but yes look at that picture but
here's the issues i know the pictures
that you're insane i know but the issue
is the wolves no no but but no the issue
is like you have this person who's like
an artist
and they're making this thing for you
that is like on your special day yeah
and they're saying they're giving it to
you like this
what do you think right and it's like
it's supposed to be special and this is
like you know like what you do to a
sixth grader you put it on the
refrigerator right with the macaroni pan
what do you want me to do with it frame
it yeah
that's what i'm saying what do you do
that thing that's what she's asking it's
like it's a difficult you're put in a
difficult position well you don't say
anything you take it and you burn it but
the other thing is like you're not going
to beat that original
first of all
amazing [ __ ] grown wolves i don't
like how nobody's addressing no i the
other thing is they're in front of a
[ __ ] wall everything in that picture
is a dime i i thought that picture was
photoshopped it's real yeah i know that
picture is amazing you know what that
there the couple is so good looking
that the and then the dogs are so
striking that put the dogs in the back
because it's it's
no you don't put the dogs you're because
they're not dogs
like this
picture okay you got two
dimes with two wolves dude in front of a
[ __ ] waterfall
you shouldn't recreate this people that
i want to hang out with
you don't want to hang out with her
maybe i don't know dude i don't want to
hang out with people that have wolves
and live in the building oh i'm here
they're always like you know in like
sweatpants and like workout gear no no i
don't like couples oh i see you know oh
you don't like every time you see them
they're like this hey chris how you
doing
10 000 stops it's only
a hundred percent yeah but they're just
like i just i i've been intimidated by
these type of you know if they were
swingers
they're swingers no if i can play with
the wolves and like hang out and like
spit shop on workouts i'm in yeah they
want to go to movies you know yeah they
don't they probably have never seen
movies right i was aaron eric did you
see uh eric did you see every movie i
know you've been busy have you seen the
new jurassic park i haven't seen it yet
but i've heard bad things i heard so
much i can't wait to see it when i hear
a movie's awful i can't wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait speaking of have you watched top
gun nope not yet
top gun is unreal fantastic no it's the
best move i've seen in 10 years thank
you
bro
kill can't wait to see it now you're not
going to enjoy it that's not your
dude i stood up and [ __ ] saluted the
screen that's great
it's the nostalgia [ __ ] though man
the only thing that's nostalgic about it
is the fact that they started the movie
the same way yes right but other than
that okay it let me tell you what it
like there's no thanos in it okay right
what i'm saying is like it's just good
acting good story and perfect like
heartfelt and this old school you know
what it is tom cruise i believe this
[ __ ] and why do you but here's
my thing here it's a great point the
reason you believe him is because for
the first time his career he's accepted
oh i'm older and he takes on that older
leadership role instead of being mission
impossible 19 yeah
and he wasn't taking a 22 year old no
sometimes you know what i mean it was
what's her name jennifer conley like you
know it was like it was you know what
i'm saying it was like tom cruise
he does this thing in his movies where
you know he's doing his own stunt right
yeah so you look at it and you go man
you really are dedicated to making this
movie good so even though you know this
is like fake
i appreciate the effort that he puts in
yeah this [ __ ] is he's flying
the plane man he's taking off like he
has i saw him in the interview he's like
yeah i got my f-14 license i got my f-19
and he was like and i got my realtor's
license
oh that's hilarious no eric for [ __ ]
what yeah you need more money
yeah you want to go see a two minutes
tom cruise is
trying to sell you this [ __ ] 350 000
house i'm buying the
this goes back to my thing that i always
say acting is a [ __ ] job dude it's
easy as [ __ ] it's so easy that you learn
other jobs to do the [ __ ] job because
it ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] here's here's the
problem that's such a good point no no
no no no no no you don't understand
good points when the movie starts
wait it's ridiculous
you are ridiculous
when the movie starts before the movie
and starts it's tom cruise and the chair
goes hey thank you so much for coming to
the movie theater and i'm like what's up
no me too
no rich and i was like oh this is gonna
be terrible he goes we were waiting for
this to hit the theaters because you're
seeing real g-force real jets we worked
our ass off enjoy the movie i went oh
that's cool and then check this out
miles teller was around jet so much he
got real sick broke out in hives had to
go in this oatmeal bath right and uh he
gets his blood work done next day comes
the set time goes you're all right man
what's going on and miles teller goes
dude they found jet fuel in my
bloodstream could have killed me and you
know what tom cruise said this is an
ultimate [ __ ] primo actor he looks
and goes you have jet fuel in your blood
and uh mouse telegraphers i was born
with it what's up
wait hold on hold on do you want so this
is a bit different
a bit like
they couldn't shoot for two days because
he broke out in hives couldn't figure
out what it was that he was allergic to
food or something they found out because
he was around jet so much somehow it got
in his bloodstream which is very
dangerous first of all i'm not having
time oh [ __ ] it's dangerous tom cruise
hears it this one's great tom cruise
here he goes i was born with it
but he wasn't
he's just an actor
no he's you know what i disagree with
you tom cruise is not just an actor okay
he's got that thing and you know what
you know what i challenge you
you got a little bit of that thing too
that's why [ __ ] are out here
getting tattoos on their body with your
thing
so it's not just no view
it's not just about being an actor or
whatever it's when you have that thing
the only thing that can stop it or or
tarnish it would be like slapping chris
rock at the oscars yeah that's what
could like
alter it yes because that [ __ ]
had that thing too you know what i mean
but anyways it's a great movie
he
has that it's also pro america like you
know what are you from russia no you're
from russia no but that's why that's why
it's [ __ ] killing yeah it's tricking
you no it's not tricky that's real dude
oh my god dude i'm from i'm from [ __ ]
i'm from the corner of real avenue an
authentic
street right and
real avenue authentic street yeah
you're so dumb dude you got to see it
what does aaron rodgers have to say yeah
take your wife to i'm telling you i'll
see it i'll see it yeah because my dad
was in the navy was like and not only is
it good because he's like it's authentic
cause my dad used to work on
he was my neighbor yes on authentic
street yeah dude
all right neighbors on authentic street
stop the king wing sting whoever else
may be a lot of foreign's
getting married abroad obviously from
scotland
we went to vegas to get married didn't
invite anyone
just me and her was good that's cool
buzz buzz
whatever that kind of
so wait uh he got married just by
himself with the with him and his
girlfriend what are you saying like that
didn't make any made like like
destination wedding is what he was but
also like but it was just the two of
them
whatever fits your [ __ ] like if that's
your thing do it man i mean honestly i
made a courthouse bro if you i got a
buddy who's like the girl's like i just
want to go to the courthouse he's like
no i want to have a party i'm like bro
buy a [ __ ] house let's tell my girl
here's the thing when we bought our
house to go listen we can do whatever
you want to do or we can take that money
invested into this house look at this
house they get you
down the parents paid for the wedding
i'm glad i had a wedding that's how it
should work oh yeah yeah i'm glad i had
a i look i look at all like
all my groups of friends who don't know
each other
i i i was so moved by the people that
showed up and and it was just like i was
like this is great when when are all
these people gonna be together at my
wedding and my funeral yeah you know
what i mean you're not gonna be there
for that one
so it's like i felt like this is a great
thing but i will say this
all about destination weddings oh yeah
oh i'm not it oh yeah i'm not yeah make
it easy though if it's a fun it is easy
it's not though here's here's
no no especially as touring comics like
it's a nightmare yeah true i was able to
go to yours because san francisco i had
to schedule yours i was in portland like
it sucks i was so happy though i got
adam ray's save the date and i'm like
let me check if i'm on the road i'm not
on the road i'm like oh good i can go
yeah it is hard it is hard oh so sorry
that you two rich [ __ ] can't make money
that one day
okay
we're disappointing thousands of people
if we don't go hundreds of thousands
hundreds of thousands
are you kidding me what are you talking
about i sell tickets i'll be in by the
way i'll be in dallas ah that's what it
is i'll be in dallas
yeah hopefully there's no weddings
july 14th or 16th so i'm in fort wayne
indiana i don't know where you're going
i haven't even
that's all i think about i like a good
destination wedding because like i tell
you this i went to adam devine's wedding
yeah where was it at and it was in cabo
yeah and i had seen funny [ __ ] greatest
time yep and it was like one i got the
wedding discount on a really expensive
hotel so that was nice yeah okay all
right right so you got that but then it
was like just being with people like oh
we're at the pool we're at the buffet oh
no i had such a good time
even like you're like you say what you
want you had a destination wedding this
guy [ __ ] counts
thursday
that's not destination
it took longer to get to your wedding
than it did to mine no [ __ ]
we got there the day before and there
was a lot of traffic and i was in
traffic with rachel like this is chris
getting back at me right now
it was like it was already an hour the
other thing is like
i i did i haven't seen marshall in five
years i didn't move with marshall i've
seen him since oh really i was in one of
one of his movies marshall's great uh uh
rick grassman i haven't seen him since i
started pandemic yeah yeah no no it's
cool yeah it's cool to see these guys
looking looking rich yeah yeah yeah
really
i know yeah he was like he looked like
josh lieberman is there yeah i haven't
seen him in person i've seen him in
forever yeah i was surprised he was
there yeah
gotta [ __ ] it's all love that was a
good time yeah i felt like whoever was
there
they support you and love you it was
great yep and theo was dealing with some
family things so that's why he didn't
i just said to the i was like yeah i'm
sorry i wish you were coming he's like i
wish i could get over there man but i
don't know what he's doing i called him
on my way home oh yeah he was asked he
was like how was it man he said i said
you got my address and he never got back
to me still yeah when i was saying i was
like because i i'm you know what my
thing was i'm not chasing anybody to
come yeah nobody's a friend you know i
say hey you wanna come if i don't hear
back i'm like okay yeah i'm not gonna be
like hey man why aren't you coming i
don't you know i said can you come if
you can't come i don't care but but i i
won't say this and this isn't you know i
was important i couldn't i get it no i
get it but i was like i couldn't wait to
like i know how much i love somebody if
i i was like excited to go to yours i
was sad i missed george other people the
weddings and like not happening dude
i'll make something up i'll be like oh
man i got a piece of time it's fine if
you can't come it's fine if you can't
but it's not though it is i mean just at
least say it you know like i had people
that were i'm like
like you know chris was like are they
coming or not i'm like
you know and they just never responded
right and it's like that's so rude but
that's why i you know what for me i just
went i'm not gonna worry about this the
ones that really like they want like i
like the workaholics boys didn't come
but they all told me why like blake sent
me a really nice yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean yeah adam was like dude i'm
shooting uh what you call it and
anders's brother got married yeah on the
10th sure you know so i was like okay
yeah
but when when nobody when they just
don't hit you up at all no but just say
something about that shouldn't have even
invited you i know
i felt bad
i've been telling you hey man
i rescheduled uh san fran i can come it
was like a two day notice yeah yeah
that's i was like i don't need food not
just give me a piece of cake and whiskey
man it's also different because like if
you guys couldn't come you guys are my
friends it's fine like i [ __ ] i
understand we talk all the time but it's
like some people it's like oh
i i guess we're not friends you know
what i mean
i got to say something what i remember i
remember i five years ago i was on
bobby's podcast and i was talking to him
about like you know when you don't get
invited or learn about
one of your comic friends big life
events it makes you feel like you're not
really their friend after now getting
married i totally changed my mind on
that now so because i used to think
about like i thought i was really close
with sebastian yeah he didn't invite me
to his wedding and i was like oh man
maybe we're not friends right now i get
it
i get it it's just like you you know for
me we're in a certain budget
i can't invite everybody i just think
who is currently in my life all the time
right now let me invite those people
right now and it's not it's not a it's
not a slight on the other people no i do
understand that but what i'm saying is
if you get invited and you don't have
anything going on like and i i was i did
do a caption for the poster picture i
was gonna say anybody who didn't come
that's known chris and he invited and
for you for some whatever reason you
didn't want to show support [ __ ] all
y'all yeah that's what i want to put you
know it's like i i get it because like i
don't depends on the closeness level
like you know who you're really close to
because like we were going to go on our
honeymoon we had this whole big back and
forth i was like well if we go we can
come back and i wanted to go to the
party even before the wedding so we
we're going yeah yeah today we're
leaving
we decided to like i don't know so we
started it you know yeah since it was a
day
the people that you came up with the
people that you came up with that could
have made it didn't come
i'm out
yeah i don't know i mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] it depends on what it is and
what went down and what you had to do
but but but and and if you and again if
you say i can't come
that's fine but for the people that are
like you know because krista was like
are they coming or not we had to know
for the thing and it's like they didn't
even respond one guy i texted a very you
know close friend owner for years and i
was just like are you coming or you know
let me know and he's like oh i didn't
get the email and i was like yeah but we
also sent you a [ __ ] mail
as well and then then you just just go
no no no i'm out you don't want to force
them you got it yeah yeah don't tell me
you didn't get the email right the tags
i mean
you know i got your address i guess i
invited
someone else i uh like you know
and i was like yo
like a month ago i was like hey man yeah
you coming yeah you know it's just kind
of like i know you got this thing yeah
i know you gotta say oh well my girl
blah blah blah i'm like okay
that then i'm out i'm just like all
right well then i'm not gonna start i
ask people one time
that's it no if it's important to make
it but as far as honeymoons how'd you
guys decide yours is surprising i'm
gonna go to london we're gonna go to
london yeah yeah oh you're bringing
yourself no i'm not no no
that's good she was like on the
outskirts are you going like downtown
now we're going downtown bro
i want to do that
i don't want to do it you you how long
you gonna be going six days seven days
are you ready to be away from calvin for
six days no
i'm not surprised i'm surprised that you
guys aren't taking them i know i want
you you almost should take your parents
and just have them be yeah
i want to and where are you going eric
we're going to cancun okay my girl's
cousin she works for this luxury such
and such place that like does like
vacations and stuff so she got us like
we're going to this like boutique
you know what i mean a thousand dollar
spa credit we're getting picked i just
go to the airport i want to be in a city
i don't want to be and she was like
let's go here let's go there for like
yeah that's so weird i sting that yeah i
stink cities are all especially the
comments
they're all the same go to toronto the
weather's awesome in la we're gonna go
to cancun like it's fine it's cool but
then you gotta eat you gotta eat at the
[ __ ] two restaurants they have around
there do you know what i mean it's more
than two i know but it's like if you go
if you're universal it's all inclusive i
know but that's where i don't want to be
i don't want to be all-inclusive no me
neither i want to be i want to find a
good coffee shop i want to go out
because she loves history
yeah you're right i do but she's like if
there was like a hotel next to the next
to the [ __ ] coffee bean he would be
like oh this is great babe i'm going
down to the coffee bean
our honeymoon's in pasadena yeah
what else you got nick that's it that's
it that's good yeah holy [ __ ] oh my god
yeah well congrats fellas thanks if
there's anybody in london that wants to
[ __ ] do a tattoo by the way hit me up
i want to i want to get a tattoo there
um and then your wedding that's
something i don't know yeah something
like that means something i want some
more time and then uh i'm gonna be i am
gonna be in dallas i am gonna be in uh
denver at the bellco theater get tickets
at crystallia.com i'm going to be all
the i'm in jacksonville i'm in uh
kansas i'm in a lot of different places
uh boston at the wang theater so hit it
up yeah and then i'm back on the road
the trash panda summer tour start kicks
up july 14th 16th fort wayne indiana new
club out there and then i'm in uh san
diego the following week that's in july
that's san diego laugh factory the one
where i open up for chris that's why i
decided to do the club it's a great club
in the heart of san diego laugh factory
san diego
and then i'm in by august 4th through
the 6th i'm in baltimore
and then it is
september 8th appleton wisconsin oh
appleton wisconsin just got added and
then we have houston in boston tickets
at thickboy.com get you some but uh fort
wayne indiana let's do it eric what do
you got doug i don't got a lot of stuff
because i haven't been thinking about it
but i am going to be at the creek in the
cave in austin
july 15th through the 17th and i know i
have an irvine improv day coming up i
just forgot i'm just doing one night at
irvine cool and i'm gonna put i'm gonna
have all this stuff up once i get back
from get back to my honeymoon i'm gonna
be back to being
you know eric griffin the comedian yeah
i know i haven't thought about it yeah i
haven't even thought about it you know
what i mean because it's been so like
you know i've just been in a love haze
yeah i'm actually so glad you got
married a week after me it was just i
felt like it was like
i'm having the two weeks
yeah you know what i mean it was great
can i plug something never done this
before live show live podcast at irvine
improv july 13th me and my two buddies
are joining kate casey from reality life
with kate casey wow which is insane
congratulations out loud but everybody
imprisoned
wow oh no
and make sure also that we issue a shout
out make sure you check out uh
theovonne.com right yeah
all over yeah
yeah yeah so he's gonna be out someplace
in some redneck town so make sure you
like look for him and like you know and
he'll be on he's just handling his
family business he'll be back though
yeah of course shout out to mr thief i'm
used to it at this point they don't care
all right guys love you
it's the king and the sting back up in
this thing i just got a call that said
they wanted the wing they got me working
all night long
how many times i gotta make this
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's the king and the sting and
the wing